-Our first guest tonight is an
Oscar and Emmy nominee.
She returns to host "SNL"
this week
with musical guest Dua Lipa.
She also stars in
"Wonder Woman 1984,"
which will be in select theaters
in IMAX on Christmas Day
and available the same day
on HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the show,
one of the all-time best,
Kristen Wiig, everybody!
Whoooo!
Whoo!
-I don't know how to walk in
heels anymore.
-They're so beautiful!
Look at those beautiful
white boots!
-Oh, thanks! Well, thanks.
-Look at you with your new
white boots!
-[ Chuckles ] They're not mine
Um, yeah, it's ver--
-That's good.
-Well, 'cause I don't wear shoes
anymore.
-Isn't it amazing?
-I have slippers.
-I'm just wearing running shoes.
Look at that.
-That's okay.
-If Eric -- you know Eric.
-Oh, don't show him those.
-I mean, if he knew that I
showed those,
I'm gonna get an earful.
-I've discovered socks
with little, like,
treads on them.
-Oh, yeah, they're very --
-So you don't even have to
wear your slippers.
-[ Laughs ]
-Don't -- Tread socks,
So you're saying that --
-Like socks with little like
rubber things
so you don't slip and fall
-You didn't know they existed.
We took our --
-They're pretty great.
-In simpler times when you wer
allowed to do this,
we took our boys to a trampoline
park.
And at a trampoline park,
you got to get
the socks with treads.
Even the adults.
And that's when I realized
-Oh, well...
-'Cause then life's great.
At the end of the day...
But I will say Alexi
shamed me once.
On a normal day once,
she was like,
"Are you wearing the
trampoline socks?"
-With your shoes?
[ Both laugh ]
-How are you?
-It's good. Yeah.
You know, it's crazy times but
it's trying to be, you know...
Yeah.
-It's really nice to have yo
in the building.
This obviously must be nic
to be in a place that is sort of
a comfort place now,
I would imagine -- "SNL?"
-Yeah. Yeah, it's home.
I mean, you know how it is
-Yeah.
You see all the -- It's
obviously different now,
but, you know, 'cause masks an
testing every day,
but that's just, you know, wha
it is.
It's like, you know, it's home
It's the best.
-You were so prolific in you
time there coming up
with characters, and I'm
wondering, like,
did that muscle go away?
Do you still develop characters?
-[ Laughing ] Kind of.
I mean, I still wear wigs around
the house.
-You do?
Does that mean just have loose
wigs?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-And they're in a bin called
Loose Wigs.
[ Both laugh ]
No, I have a wig...costume..
trunk.
[ Both chuckle ]
-On a normal -- Like, how ofte
do you wear a wig --
-I mean, I'm not --
[ Laughing ] It's not like -
It's not a normal thing wher
like I just wake up
in the morning and go,
"You know what..."
-[ Laughs ]
-"...I'm Cheryl today."
But they are fun to put on the
babies.
-Oh, right.
"cause your babies now
are just over -- You have
twins -- just over a year.
-Yes.
-I mean, it must be so exciting.
I mean, they can't appreciat
yet how lucky they are,
but I imagine all parents become
comedians to their children.
You just constantly are doin
characters.
Are they laughers?
Are they smilers?
-Yeah, they're definitely
smilers.
She laughs more than he does
[ Laughing ]
Actually, I shouldn't say that
She's a happier baby.
-[ Laughs ]
No, they're both happy.
-He watches a lot of MSNBC
-He does, he does.
No, but they're not --
they're not walking yet bu
they're crawling,
and they crawl very fast.
-Gotcha.
-And there's two.
So, you know,
sometimes they go in two
different directions
and you have to choose a child
-And on those days you're...
You have to choose a child
-...you're pretty happy to hav
treads on your socks.
[ Both laughing ]
Now, we've talked about --
that we were --
for many years before we had
children, we were loving parents
to our dogs --
Frisbee and Moose.
How is Moose taking to the
babies?
-Uh, good...
-Okay.
I think they're -- you know,
they don't know.
So they're just like, "I'm gonna
grab her tail,"
and she doesn't love that.
-Yeah.
I don't think Frisbee -- I think
if Frisbee could talk,
she would not have kind things
to say about our boys.
-Yeah. Well, yeah,
they would be like,
"First of all, what are yo
doing here?"
-Yeah.
-And "I want their attention."
But, you know.
-Yeah.
-It's all good.
-I did not realize
how autobiographical one of your
characters was.
You were kind enough to brin
this photo
of your beloved character Gill
and then just you.
[ Both laugh ]
-I blame -- Okay, there's a lo
of things I blame for that
One, I was in a wedding.
So that's why I have
flowers in my hair and I'm
wearing a dress.
Two, I had perms my entire
childhood.
And I didn't -- my mom was like,
"She's gonna have curly hair."
I had no -- I was young.
I didn't know.
-Have you ever, like, looped
back with her
to ask about why a perm wa
chosen?
-No, I'm gonna ask her
right now.
-[ Laughing ]
Mom, if you're watching...
And also, there's some Sun-I
in my hair, there.
And when you have brown hair
which I do naturally,
when you put Sun-In in you
hair, it turns red.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, it's red
from the Sun-In.
-It's like
the Little Orphan Annie.
[ Laughing ]
Yeah, I mean, it's so curly.
Oh, my God.
I do wish I had that hair now.
-I do like that the way we'v
done this is it's like --
it's Gilly is remembering he
childhood.
-[ Laughs ] She's looking --
She's looking at her.
-We're gonna talk more whe
we're right back after thi
with Kristen Wiig.